foreign
[Music]
first of all before I get started thanks
everybody again for all of the support
on Twitch and YouTube
if you like my content you can subscribe
or you can throw me a YouTube sub I'd
really appreciate it
um and without further ado
let's get this show on the road
2229c srix
good luck and here we go
um let me know if my audio is sufficient
I hope I'm not peaking welcome YouTubers
to another speedrun game
and we are off
now
never mind
I was going to say as promised uh I'm
going to start playing my my actual
repertoire uh which includes the real
Lopez that is my main opening what I
want to play here since we're facing
Knight F6 is not the Belgrade Gambit not
the four night Scotch but an opening
that I have been playing and analyzing
pretty extensively I would say for about
two years
um this is in my opinion an incredibly
underrated weapon and I say weapon uh as
a very particular choice of words I
think it is a weapon I think it's a
dangerous system
um and it's a system that flies under
the radar and a lot of black players
because they don't study it they don't
really know how to position their pieces
uh and so you are seriously contending
for an advantage with this move it's
called the gleck system it's named after
Igor gleck uh who is he's still alive
he's a Russian Grandmaster I think he's
in his 60s now and at his Peak he was in
the 2600s now he's you know uh coaching
so he's in the 2400s and gleck uh I want
to say in the 80s and 90s but I really
don't know exactly when he developed and
really fleshed out a lot of the ideas of
this system which in which you play G3
now there are several move orders uh
through which you can reach the gleck
system you can play Knight C3 and G3 you
can play Knight F3 and G3 but the basic
idea of the guac is the finquet of the
bishop against uh in the king pawns game
I'm not gonna introduce any specific
ideas until we we find out which setup
our opponent chooses because a lot will
depend on where black chooses to
position the d-pawn there are systems
where black plays D6 usually after
developing the bishop outside the pawn
chain which I think is what our opponent
is aiming to do most books recommend the
more principled counter Central strike
D5 and that leads to a completely
different type of position of course
some ideas are shared uh but there's a
big distinction between the open Center
and closed Center position so our
opponent chooses uh the line which I
think is the most popular if you
actually check the database most people
who don't really know what to do with
black they develop in precisely this
manner
now the first step to playing the guac
system is to complete our King side
development and play the move D3 this is
sort of stage one uh this is rather
self-explanatory and you can start with
a variety of different move orders I
like to start with D3 because it's a
little bit more flexible you're kind of
delaying castling
okay H6 is a move that you often see
played by black we are not really
intending to play Bishop G5 in any case
but H6 is a pretty healthy move that uh
that people kind of default to
um okay so now we Castle
and black castles okay so now we enter
stage two we have essentially completed
our kingside development and there is a
branching off point we have two main
ways of playing the Glock system one is
uh A variation that the computer doesn't
approve of but that I have played with
great success online and that is the
system connected with the move Bishop E3
but the way that Igor gleck intended uh
for people to play this position is to
set up a king's Indian like plan where
you prepare the f2f4 pawn strike and
start attacking on the king's side
um that is usually done by playing H3
moving the king to H2 and that is of
course in order to unpin the F Pawn then
moving the Knight away from F3 usually
backwards to D2 and finally you're ready
to push F to F4 this is the traditional
uh way of playing the gleck and this is
actually the line that is chosen usually
by by the computer the second type of
system involves playing Bishop E3 and
posing black with the Dilemma of whether
black wants to trade Bishops on E3 and
if you play the re Lopez or the Italian
you should know that with the semi-openf
file uh White gets some serious
attacking chances connected with the
Knight transfer Tab 5 and other various
attacking ideas I want to play the main
line in this game just as an
introductory because it is sort of an
introduction to the gleck system so
let's play them of H3 of course by
playing H3 we are not committing to
anything in particular H3 in and of
itself is a pretty healthy improving
move but with our next move we already
have to indicate our intentions right
the time has come for us to choose
whether we're playing Bishop E3 or
whether we're playing H2 now A5 is a
pretty impressive move our opponent is
kind of crossing their T's and dotting
their eyes
um we can push A4 we can push A4 but in
Blitz Games the way that I have liked to
play this system is to allow black to
push A4
and so let's play King H2 and then stop
the pawn with A3 or even sometimes allow
black to play A3 which is not that
dangerous because we can push B3
so let's go King H2 and continue
preparing uh the the main gleck plan
with an eventual f2f4
so hopefully I was able to
you know
explain in relatively clear terms what
the what the Zen of this opening is and
again that is to push F4 and you might
be sitting there and saying okay I get
it I get what we're preparing why are we
preparing what is so great about the
move F4 and that's a deeper question
that I'll tackle after the game and
maybe I'll get a chance to demonstrate
that depending on how our opponent
responds now most people uh even most
GMS they end up playing Bishop E6
because that is the only reasonable
Square for blacks Bishop of course
Bishop D7 is possible but that's quite
passive and after Bishop D6 we will
indeed drop our Knight back to D2 and we
will finally be ready to push F4
um I think in response to the move A4
grabbing space on the queen side like I
said we're gonna freeze Black's pawns
with A3 and of course the pawn on A4
will then be a long-term weakness that
can be targeted by the Knight
uh if black plays Bishop E6 and queen D7
that doesn't actually threaten anything
and that is
one of the positive byproducts of the
move King H2 which is that the H3 Pawn
is now safely protected so if black
constructs the classic battery we won't
need to waste the tempo to defend the H3
Pawn right
97 now 97 is a relatively unconventional
move I don't think it's a bad move but I
think it changes in large part how we
choose to tackle this position
now I'd point out that by playing H3 and
King H2 like I said earlier we're still
not particularly it's not committal what
we're doing right we can change up our
plans we don't we still don't have to
push f2f4 we can Resort back to even a
move like Bishop E3 would not be bad
here we're not going to play that
now what do I see when I look at the
move 90 so 97 clearly relinquishes
Black's grip over the D4 Square that's
the drawback of the Knight transfer to
G6 and so a very thematic way to try to
punish black would be to push D4
ourselves I mean again if you're a real
Lopez player you you know to look for
the D4 Pawn strike in various moments so
D4 forces the exchange
because after D4 if the bishop drops
back we went upon the D4 e takes D4
Knight takes D4 that is also a structure
that I've had a lot in the Glock system
and because of our Pawn on e4 we have a
slightly Superior control over the
center and I think white has a minuscule
minuscule Advantage after D4 so that's
one candidate move the other candidate
move is to play Knight D2 and to follow
through on our plan with F4
um presumably presumably after Knight D2
black intends to play Knight G6 then we
would push F4
black would maybe trade on F4 and does
anybody see what potentially nasty move
uh black could face us with in in that
position not actually not that dangerous
but it's a move to be aware of in that
situation it's the smooth Knight G6 to
H4 and the H4 square is a little bit
nasty because it targets our Bishop on
G2 and we certainly don't want to give
our Bishop away because then our King is
left without protection so we would have
to drop our Bishop back to H1 in that
position and things look a little bit
flimsy on the king side in that
situation so it's potentially rewarding
because if we can push that forward we
can get the attack going on the king
side you can actually Crush black uh in
those situations but it does come with a
certain degree of risk because yes we do
we do weaken our Kings significantly by
pushing F4 but let me take 30 seconds to
think about this in silence we're
deciding between D4 and Knight D2 here I
think I know what people want me to play
yeah I think okay Knight H4 also was
proposed by but Knight H4
yeah Knight H4 is possible but then
black plays Knight G6
then we could maybe play Knight F5 so
that's also kind of an interesting way
to treat this position
we could also play Knight G1 we could
absolutely play Knight G1 here uh no why
not because the benefit of Knight G1
over Knight D2 is that it leaves the
diagonal open for the bishop the
drawback of Knight G1 is that it's a
little bit more passive and it
undevelops the Knight maybe after Knight
she won black could play a move like D5
and Counter-Strike in the center
it's a hard decision to make a 97 is not
a move that I'm familiar with so
I'm uh I myself am a little bit confused
but let's try it let's try Knight D2
let's let's uh play according to the
textbook and let's see if Mr gleck knew
what he was talking about and if I lose
I can blame it on gleck like he he
proposed this plan of Knight D2 F4 and
he didn't know what he was talking about
um after the game we'll explore the
other options
um we'll explore there was a reason I
didn't play D4 the reason for those who
are curious what what swayed my decision
not to play D4 it was this line e takes
D4 Knight takes D4 and then see if you
can find an active way for black to
fight for the center what move in that
position might potentially be nasty
because it kind of liquidates the
position
so after after Deport e takes D4 Knight
takes D4
what might have dissuated me from that
yeah D5 D5 in that position I'll show it
after the game okay so let's just close
our eyes and push F4
we've made all of the necessary
arrangements
one important tactical Insight after ef4
gf4 and we could pre-move gf4 but no
need to do that after ef4 gf4 perhaps
some of you notice that there is this
move Knight G4 check and after H takes
G4 Queen H4 looks like Checkmate but
it's not and that is the power of the
fiancado bishop it could always block a
check on H3
okay and that's actually crucially
crucially important uh because it makes
the whole line work
okay so let me say that again e takes F4
G takes F4 Knight F6 to G4 check H takes
G4 Queen d8 to H4 check and that would
be mate were it not for Bishop H3 and
Bishop takes G4 in that position
remember that our Queen on D1 also
guards the G4 Pawn so the tactics don't
really work out for black now a useful
question to ask in such unfamiliar
positions is what would my next move be
that helps you develop an insight for
what direction you kind of want to steer
the game in and a lot depends on whether
black lazy takes F4 that really changes
the tenor of the position but if black
doesn't play e takes F4 then we're very
likely going to play one of two moves
either we're gonna reposition the Knight
back to F3 in order to open up the
bishop and increase our presence on the
king side but more likely we're gonna
push F5
and if you're a king's Indian player
then this structure with D3 E4 and F5 uh
should be quite familiar and you might
be wondering well isn't Kings Indian a
black opening and it is but the pawn
structure is much the same as is the
fiancaro bishop and after F5 the
position largely plays itself but that
will remain behind the scenes okay there
we go Knight H4
now why can't we give up this bishop why
is it such a bad idea well it weakens
the king no what do I mean by that what
it really weakens is the H3 Pawn right
if we allow black to take on G2 then in
the long run we're going to pay the
price for that for sure and black could
even then play the move Queen to D7 and
set up this relatively nasty battery
against the bishop but I just realized
that after Bishop H1 black could still
play Queen D7 but in that position we
can push F5
in that position we can push F5 and we
can slice off this battery I missed
Queen D7 I miss queen D7 hopefully we
don't get mated here the margins are
thin in this line as you can see
as you can see them okay wow our
opponent is really uh testing us but F5
there we go
and now the knight's in trouble
and now the Knight on H4 is in trouble
by the way F5 was an only move if not
for F5 we can resign because this is a
mate in one threat this is a maiden one
threat why do I say that the Knight on
that H4 is in trouble because well we
control G6 but it's interesting black
could even play Knight G6 here in fact I
would seriously consider that move if I
were Black Knight G6
why can't we take the night well then we
reopen the battery and queen takes H3 is
Checkmate because the king doesn't have
the G1 Square it's controlled by the
black Bishop
but still
if by any chance black moves the queen
away from D7 then the Knight on H4 will
be in more trouble
which is not to say that our next move
is guaranteed to be Queen E1 our next
move might very well be Knight F3
opening up the bishop and lending a
little bit of support to the king I
don't see
a great move here for black maybe there
is some tactical something tactical but
we'll see I I'm a little bit scared I'm
not gonna lie I'm definitely a little
scared here
a little dose of fear is selfie in chess
this is why Amman plays Queenie one
first yeah we could have played Queenie
one maybe maybe Queen E1 was more was
more prudent yeah probably it was to
play Queen E1 here
okay G5 but I don't I don't think black
has anything and remember with the black
system it's an opening that may appear
passive because you're doing a lot of
things on the last couple of ranks so
what you have to understand is that if
you I think the right word is unfurl if
you unfurl your pieces the attack on the
king sides comes very very quickly and I
think that's very likely to happen here
so G5
very understandable move I think our
opponent is trying to reinforce the
Knight on H4 and this changes our
approach now it it doesn't make any any
more sense to attack the Knight on H4
because that Knight is essentially
unattackable instead we should trade it
off why should we trade it up because
this Knight is in in our grill right
it's preventing us from operating on the
king's side
um yeah made in one that's kind of funny
and you already should be primed to
consider this move and this move is
Knight to F3
of course we are trying to force the
trade of knights here uh we're
threatening Knight takes H4 and then
Bishop takes H6 Etc and if black
acquiesces to the trade then I think
we're gonna take back with the queen in
order to get our Queen into an attacking
position on the king side
and then these pawns on H6 and G5 will
be very eminently targetable by our
pieces but also by the H3 Pawn which can
move up to H4 and be used as a battering
ram to try to shatter Black's kingside
pawns notice that Black's position is a
lot more passive than ours because we
have this epic Pawn chain where that
pawn and F5 is almost like a plug that's
preventing black from effectively
carrying his forces over to the king
side so once we start our King side
attack it might end up being decisive in
the span of a couple moves
I like that this is over my head's a
standard average but I want you to tell
me exactly what is over your head like
what specifically have I said that
hasn't been clear and if so you can ask
me to repeat it or explain it more
clearly in the chat
um and I'd be happy to okay Knight G6
which I mentioned right this is this is
a possible move
and it's a very ingenious move but it
also might be a blunder we need to
calculate now F take G6 Queen takes H3
as Checkmate but the reason it's
Checkmate is because the G1 square is
controlled by the black Bishop so once I
make that observation you should
immediately think ah but what if we
start with D4
and we chase this bishop away and then
once the bishop moves away then what if
we take the plunge and take the Knight
on G6
well black plays Queen takes H3 check
and we play King G1 and it's still very
very scary but maybe we get away with it
I need to calculate that myself for a
bit I'm inclined not to go for it but
because we're trying to play principal
chess I owe it to the chats to try to
calculate this out I don't like it
though my intuition tells me not to go
for it by the way
because we have other maybe we even
played D4
and then make a different move but let's
think
Knight takes G5 I don't like that we
could just play Bishop G2 for example
and secure this Pawn
hmm could play D4 and Bishop G2
could play Bishop G2 and D4
I'm spoiled for Choice here I like okay
let's start with D4
let's start with D4 okay why am I
starting with D4 because this is a
relatively non-committal move and I say
relatively that's an important asterisk
what is the drawback of the move d4 who
can tell me what what is the only
drawback of this move
I'll explain after the game because
there's a lot of variations there that
scare me yeah we weaken the E4 Pawn now
we weaken the E4 Pawn but the E4 Pawn is
still nicely protected by the Knight and
it's an easy pawn to defend when you
when you're assessing whether it's worth
creating a weakness one of the questions
you should be asking is well how easy is
it to defend that weakness with pieces
and it's quite easy right if necessary
we could bring our Queen up to D3 we can
move our Rook to E1 it's not like this
Pawn on e4 is about to collapse and our
whole position collapses with it no
okay now I would like to reinforce the
threat of f takes G6 to reinforce that
threat we need to protect the H3 Pawn to
protect the H3 Pawn we need to move our
Bishop up to G2 that would reinforce the
threat and force this Knight to move by
forcing this Knight to move we make it
more possible for us to play H4 or even
sacrifice a knight on G5 which you
should already be thinking about because
that's a very thematic and typical type
of sacrifice we could even consider in a
classical game I would be considering
Knight takes G5 here although it's a
little bit speculative
but it might actually be the best move
so let me let me devote a little bit a
little bit of time to that Knight takes
G5 HD Bishop G5 Knight H7 Bishop H6
actually that looks like it works the
more I look at it the more I realize
that just looks completely overwhelming
and then we've got Knight D5 on top of
that no it's I think it just works I
think this should be the best move yeah
I'm I'm actually very confident that we
can get away with this very confident
that we can get away with this and
there's many components to it too much
to delve into with six minutes on the
clock
but one of the big things to realize is
that this is not such a big sacrifice
and I wish that this was this were
explained more often to beginner players
and newer players which is that not all
sacrifices are created equal not all
sacrifices are the same level of
commitment sacrificing a rook is very
different from sacrificing a minor piece
for two pawns which is what we're doing
here sacking a minor piece for two pawns
is barely even a sacrifice which means
that the threshold for proving to
yourself that this is worth going for is
much more much less strict if you can
con if you can evaluate the sacrifice
and you come to the conclusion that you
have a very strong attack and likely
that attack will lead to Victory you can
go ahead and Sack which is exactly what
I did here I think this is GG but I
didn't calculate as heavily as I would
if I were sacrificing a rook because
there the margins are a lot thinner if
the sacrifice fails you're likely to
lose the game pretty quickly okay I'm
belaboring an obvious point but just
keep that in mind
this is GG in just a couple of moves I
think
so all that I calculated was H takes G5
Bishop takes G5 Knight F6 drops back to
H7 and the bishop moves into H6 that's
where I stopped my calculation and
evaluated the position
and that position to me looks completely
winning almost resignable in a classical
game no he's not going to Res
at this level I don't think anybody's
gonna resign
nor should he nor do I want him to
that would Rob us of the opportunity to
demonstrate attacking principles which I
think can be very instructive
okay so Bishop takes G5
uh Knight H7 yes very nice okay so first
things first we need to move our Bishop
okay well technically we also have this
cute move we have this cute move Knight
D5 I wonder if anybody saw this Knight
D5 is a is a cute move because Knight
takes G5 Knight F6 check but your
emphasis in such positions should not be
on writing a tactics book or trying to
be fancy it should be on making very
simple functional moves Your Instinct
should be to play very simple chess and
it's much simpler and much it lends much
more clarity to the position to move the
bishop away
but the other reason is that we want to
keep the G file open we want to move the
bishop because we want to be able to put
a rook on G1 or a queen on G4 and to pin
this Knight okay
um all right just a moment
okay rookie
so we're spoiled for Choice here I think
in this position white has a couple of
ways to win
what is the bottom line the bottom line
is that we want to be able to threaten F
takes G6 and we want to threaten that in
order to move Force this Knight to move
and we want to force this Knight to move
so that we could deliver a devastating
check on G1 so we want to defend the H3
Pawn how should we defend it well Bishop
G2 is how we wanted to do it earlier the
drawback of Bishop G2 is that it covers
up the G file and we want to be able to
go Rook G1
Queen H5 is interesting but might run
into Knight F6 right we don't
necessarily want to lead with our Queen
although Queen H5 Knight F6 Queen G5
probably wins the game
yeah Queen H5 Knight F6 Queen G5
and if the Knight moves back to H7 there
the queen can drop back to G3 or even to
G2 for instance I just didn't want to
allow Bishop takes D4 I didn't want to
allow Bishop takes D4 letting the bishop
enter the defense
Queen G4 also allows Knight F6 also
allows Bishop takes D4 you know what
move I think is on no one's radar but
it's actually a very accurate move is
the move Queen up to D3 and I know that
looks doesn't look like the sexiest
attacking move but what it does is it
guards the H Pawn laterally and it
guards the D4 Pawn so it keeps Black's
Bishop away from the defense okay so
Queen D3 to me is my first instinct here
actually
Queen D3
probably not the best move though I
think Queen H5 might be stronger but
Queen H5 maybe is a little bit too
concrete for my tastes let's go for
Queen D3
yeah it's a nice move because the queen
on D3 is so well placed it's out of the
way of the other pieces it's guarding H3
so we're threatening to take the Knight
and restore material equality and here's
another positive byproduct of this move
what I'm noticing is that the queen is
aiming diagonally at the G6 Pawn so
after we take on G6 who can tell me how
we can involve the queen directly into
the attack without moving it without
moving it
yeah E5 exactly exactly E5
E5
E5 is exactly right and then the queen
diagonally attacks
uh the G6 the G6 Pawn Queens don't move
like that yeah Queen E5 is not exactly
how a queen moves
our opponent is thinking but the
position is essentially hopeless I mean
we have to demonstrate some accuracy but
once we re-establish material equality I
feel like the attack will then
essentially play itself
of gfg5 of course Rook G1 is threatened
as well
the attack is completely overwhelming
because look at Black's pieces on the
queen side Black's pieces are entirely
out of the game
and Black's Queen is entirely out of the
game black just doesn't have enough beef
uh black just didn't have enough beef on
the king side to even come close to
defending what we're gonna throw at him
so one good test of your understanding
attacking understanding is do you look
at this position and are you on the same
page with me that this is completely
winning like do do you conceptualize
without calculating a single variation
why White's position is completely
winning that's a good question ask
yourself to test your intuition
okay Knight f8 okay what now so of
course we can take the Knight rather can
anybody provide an even stronger
alternative
borrowing an idea from a little bit
earlier is there a move that we could
throw in that doesn't cost us anything
yeah Knight D5 looks fantastic Knight T5
looks fantastic we can play it without
calculating because we're threatening
the fork on F6 and then on the next move
we could take on G6
now there are two ways that I could see
us winning this game and converting this
Advantage I've talked about this at
length before which is that when people
what are the limitations that people
have when they're attacking one of the
biggest ones is that when people attack
they get into what I call Checkmate mode
you know and you in your mind the the
success condition of the attack is only
Checkmate in your mind unless you find a
Checkmate the attack will have failed
that is very much not the case and you
need to be comfortable in many cases
converting an attack into something like
a decisive material advantage just
basically taking a bunch of pieces that
could very well be the best way to
convert your attack into a win winning
material using your opponent's king in
order to as a vehicle to winning a bunch
of material that could be a much easier
way at times of winning the game than
searching for some Checkmate okay so we
should talk less and move more F takes
G6 obviously we recapture the Knight and
the reason I'm saying that is everybody
should be seeing that Knight F6 is now
possibility of a fork and if if
necessary we have in our pocket the
option of winning the exchange on E8 and
then the attack of course goes nowhere
continues so we've got that simple win
in our pocket but I'm going to try to be
a lot more precise than that I'm going
to be try to be a lot more precise than
that
okay
black is cooked black is completely
cooked now
when I say this I don't mean that you
shouldn't look for checkmate right we
should look for checkmate and I think a
Checkmate exists
give me a second I have to calculate
there's one variation to sort sort out
here okay just a moment
aha
I think I found something really pretty
well really pretty I think it's an
exaggeration but quite pretty let's
start with Knight F6 check
now how do I can visual how do I
conceptualize this position well we have
Knight takes theater in our pocket but
what I'm seeing is that the black king
is out of squares any situation where a
king is out of squares by definition you
should be searching for mating patterns
now what is missing what is missing on
the king side that would enable a mating
pattern well it's the presence of the
queen well what's the ideal Square for
the queen it's clearly H5 but here's the
interesting thing Queen F3 I think is
not the most accurate move
although Queen F3 is good but Queen F3
allows Bishop takes D4 and if we play
Queen H5 in that position black can play
Bishop takes F6 and suddenly you need to
work a little bit more on the attack and
we do the same thing but prevent Bishop
takes D4 and this has been the theme of
this attack
uh throughout which is to keep this
bishop out of the game out of the
defense because this bishop is
essentially the only piece that has the
capacity to disrupt our attack with
Bishop takes D4 so we play Queen D1
you play Queen D1 and queen H5 to my
eyes is basically Unstoppable there was
one variation to calculate which is uh
the move Rook to E6 of course black can
Target the Knight with the Rook now Rook
E6 we still play Queen H5 and who can
tell me
who can tell me in this position after
Queen H5 Rook takes F6 what is the
simplest move
after Rook takes F6 I mean there are
multiple ways to win
Bishop nope not Bishop f8 that doesn't
do anything that would squander the
attack that's not mate if Rook takes F6
the G8 square is accessible for the
black king be careful
own blunder Bishop G5 Bishop back to G5
again winning material King G8 Bishop
takes F6 and it's checkmate or we win
all of Black's pieces
or or we could even we could even play
Rook takes F6 that's probably the most
clinical move as Rook takes F6
but
I like Bishop G5 because it's so prosaic
and prosaic is good prosaic is always
good
Bishop takes F6 most attacks are
conducted precisely in this manner
with simple you know wholesome moves
okay now here it's a purely academic
Rook G1 is I think the simplest move
black wants to play Queen takes H3 and
give up a rook so we'll be up a rook in
the end game there it's completely
winning right Rook G1 by the way
threatens Queen h8 checkmate
if we wanted to play clinically here if
we wanted to go for checkmate rather
than an end game up a rook the move I
would play in a classical game is Rook
F5 why in order to slice off uh the
Queen's access to H3 and then move the
other Rook over to G1 or after Rook F5
to play the move Queen H6 unfortunately
after Rook F5 there is King f8
but I see a beautiful checkmate and I
can't resist I'm gonna try to go for it
okay let's go Rook F5 Bang there is a
beautiful mate here if black follows the
line that I think he's gonna follow
of course what I would recommend to
anybody is the move Rook q1 because Rook
G1 guarantees Victory that's the beauty
of that move Rook G1 guarantees that
you're gonna win the game
Rook up five is the move that you know a
grand master would play because Victory
is already guaranteed we're up in
exchange we're not risking anything with
a move like Rook F5
so Queen H6 of course Queen H6 Queen
takes H3 check that's what I'm saying
Queen H6 Queen takes H3 and we still
have to win that end game up a full Rook
likely our opponent would have resigned
after Queen H6 but since the the theme
of this game is attack I want to finish
it off with something pretty
okay King f8
Rook G1
why Rook G1 because we're trying to
bring all of our pieces into the attack
but this also sets up a very pretty idea
I'm hoping for King E8 I'm hoping for
King E8 that will allow me to
demonstrate the uh the cool idea and you
should start thinking about what it
might be after King E8 hopefully
everybody finds the move it's not hard
yeah yeah Queen h8 check classic
deflection right you're deflecting the
Knight and then Rook comes into G8 with
Checkmate notice that in that situation
the queen on D7 and I love mating
patterns where the enemy pieces are
blocking the Escape path for the king I
think those have a particular kind of
Elegance the queen on D7 blocks the
Escape for the for the king
Jack
it's double checking because you got to
be sure it's Checkmate right Knight f8
and what's the winning idea what's the
winning idea there are several of them
but there is one that's prettier than
the others
so Rook G8 is mating Rook G8 is mating
but if you want to be even prettier
you can play the move Rook H5
what are we setting up
what are we setting up here we're
setting up an Unstoppable threat of
Queen takes f8 and Rook h8 how do I know
to look for this well anytime there's a
bishop on F6 that gives rise to
all of these combinations that involve
like a rook on HD and a bishop on F6
this is just
simple acquaintance with basic mating
patterns that's what helps you find
moves like this it's slow but black
can't do anything he's out of pieces
now again I'm not pretending that this
is some sort of beautiful like this is
necessary it's all bs anyway because
we're up a million pieces to begin with
none of this was truly truly necessary
shotgun D5 wins the queen
and ends the game
okay time to resign we can
I was gonna say we can even play Queen
E8 here and then e takes D5 and queen
takes D7 so it didn't end in Checkmate
it ended in US winning all of our
opponents pieces nice game I'm confused
can you explain again from starts finish
that is exactly what we do in the speed
run so again at a higher level my
reasoning
is harder to understand for newer
players but now we go back with a fine
tooth comb and I will try to explain
things in a more basic level
okay so the good thing about the Glick
system is that you can play it against
the pet shop right you can play Knight
C3 and essentially most people are gonna
go Knight C6
um that's that's the good thing about
the gleck if you play it it's it's a
weapon against uh both the pet shop as
well as the main Knight C6 let me pull
up uh chat because
I have my second monitors chess based on
it now
let me just copy this game into chess
space so I can run the engine when
necessary
how Theory heavy is it not very Theory
heavy it's pretty conceptual there is
there is some Theory and I'm going to
introduce you guys to some of my
analysis in the Glock system
um is this equal with best play for
black obviously I'm not pretending that
this gives white an advantage black has
several ways to equalize but it gives
you a relatively fresh position uh in
which you can learn the concepts and a
lot of players even the title players
they struggle with black because they
aren't familiar with where to position
their pieces and then you start carrying
out the main plans and you can quickly
get a good position that way
so black systems as I said are divided
into two categories there are systems
with D6 and then there's an entirely
different set of lines where black plays
D5 after D5 what you get
is e takes D5 Knight takes D5 and now
Bishop G2 so first thing to understand
is You're Not Afraid not only are you
not afraid of black taking on C3 this
Pawn structure is an integral part of
the gleck now what is the benefit for
white of playing B take C3 the drawback
is obvious you have doubled pawns you
have a nice Lany on A2 there are two
benefits the first is that it is now
much easier to carry out d2d4
controlling the center the second of
course is that the B file opens uh and
uh you can play a later Rook B1
particularly when the bishop develops
and tickle the the B7 Pawn the parallel
that I would draw is with some lines in
the Sicilian where uh for example in the
nidorf uh White is almost never advised
for example let's take uh a line that I
analyzed in a previous speedrun video
like if you get a position like this
right uh you are not advised to play
Knight takes C6 because after BC black
gets the exact same two benefits there's
the B file and there is the ease with
which black can now push D5 and control
the center uh so you can find a lot of
openings where this exchange favors the
side that has the double Pawn sorry
whoops no wrong
now here of course the situation is a
lot more double edged
uh black has a couple of moves in this
position and I won't go like too deep
into the theory I think the best move is
Bishop C5
um some people also develop their Bishop
to D6
newer players might be tempted with uh
the move E4
can anybody tell me why E4 is wrong
because if you don't know White's
response then you're gonna be you're
gonna get crushed you might go like
Knight G1 and then black gets a good
position what is the typical response to
E4 it is in fact Queen E2 which is an
idea that that should be in Your Arsenal
uh because it it features in a lot of
different openings in the scotch that is
the most famous instance of this idea
in the scotch game after white plays E5
the main line is to play Queen E7 for
black and induce uh the very awkward
Queen E2 because now this bishop on F1
has a hard time developing of course the
other uh the other idea is that now you
have the move Bishop A6 as some of you
may know and you're able to sort of keep
this Knight on D5 tactically by pinning
the pawn
so after Queen E2 in this version if
black plays Queen E7
then the first point is revealed you're
able to play Knight D4 whereas if you
play Knight D4 here you obviously lose a
pawn
so after Knight D4 Knight takes D4 C
takes D4 black has to defend this Pawn
of black does it via Bishop F5
then there is this very nice check on B5
forking the bishop and the pawn on B7
and if black plays Pawn F5 then black is
woefully underdeveloped you can castle
and black is just not able to get his
pieces out in time Bishop B6
and what should white do here what's the
right approach in a position like this
and it's not Queen B5 check because of
C6
what should white do
and white is already winning by the way
white is winning in this position
not A4
yep D3 the correct move is D3 because
you have to open the bishop and if you
open the bishop then the attack on the
long diagonal becomes devastating as
well as the possibility of playing
rookie one and pinning everything on the
e-file so for example if black castles
you go Rook B1 there's that benefit
being extracted of the initial trade
let's say black plays C6 bang Bishop
takes C6
Bang and bang wins the queen simple
tactics with pretty so therefore black
has to play Bishop D5
uh but but now you're able to
uh play takes takes and now another
beautiful tactical sequence let's see
who can find this move if you're
watching on YouTube pause the video see
if you can find another gorgeous
tactical idea here connected with this
undefended Rook now a lot of you might
think it's Queen B3 ah Fork but again
black has this pesky C6 protecting The
Rook protecting the pawn
so you need to switch the move order
and that's a good piece of advice that
my coach would always share is if you
have a move that has two components to
it consider the opposite move order like
why are you playing Queen B3 where
you're you're playing into attack B7
into attack D5
so what about Rook takes B7 first
thing takes B7 now to check black moves
up to C6 but now we inch forward to C4
and after King to D6 we can do several
different things for example we can play
well the easiest is Bishop F4 check and
rookie one check and we win absolutely
everything here
so these are a couple of illustrative
lines this is if black plays uh Queen E7
if black pushes F5 to defend here
uh then again we play D3 undermining the
spawn and using the pin and this is easy
blacks black is in huge trouble here
because the pawn will be lost so for
example Bishop D6 he takes D4 castles
you Castle
um and if black plays rookie eight then
you can jump into G5 with the Knight
which is another very typical idea in
the gleck system preparing Queen C4 with
a smothered mate and uh
the situation is dire so this is a very
important detail that E4 is bad because
of Queen E2
let's take Bishop C5 Bishop C5 the
correct move for whitest to Castle black
castles
and now we can play several moves but
the move that I like is Rook to E1 we
deploy The Rook to the open file we
pressure we pressure the E5 one rookie
eight believe it or not is already a
mistake
after rookie 8 we played D4 and white is
already better
and the point is that if black plays e
takes D4 were able to distract the Queen
by trading on E8 and then recapturing on
on D4 with an excellent position for
white we have good control of the center
we can now play the move Queen up to D3
to prepare Knight G5 and black is a hard
time finding a good arrangement for this
bishop there are some crazy lines where
black plays Bishop G4 we play Knight G5
and even though black has a check we
just cover it calmly with our Bishop and
after G6 we play the move C3 to solidify
the pawn
and then we could smoke the queen out
with Bishop to B2 and Black's position
is riddled with weaknesses the minor
pieces are bad and they're kind of just
biting on granite and this check was
scary but there's no clear follow-up
okay
so this is a pretty easy line to follow
uh the correct move here is Bishop G4
Which is far from obvious
because we can play the move H3
and if black plays Bishop H5 we can play
the move G4
and if black plays Bishop G6
here the correct move is to play Knight
takes E5 Knight takes E5
and now not Rook takes E5
because after Bishop D6 black gets
martial style compensation by pushing F5
essentially black gets a quick attack on
the king side and an overwhelming
compensation for the pawn is there an
alternative in this position who can
tell me a simple move that recovers the
piece on our terms rather than on
Black's terms yeah you throw in the move
d4 in order to go after the bishop and
in order to open up your own bishop and
it's very very hard for black to
equalize here in fact the only way to do
it is this crazy computer move F5
leaving both pieces on pre
almost all other moves are really bad
for black like if the bishop moves now
we play Rook takes C5 and the position
is excellent most people will play
Bishop takes D4 but after C takes D4 we
get the bishop pair and we get an
overwhelming initiative Knight C6 Bishop
A3 is an excellent move
and we just attacked takes takes D5 95
Queen D4 D6 is a possibility we're just
much much better here
um so very very hard for black to
actually equalize in practice
if black plays the more modest
developing move Bishop D6
uh then we Castle black castles and here
because Black's control over the D4
square is diminished we can play the
immediate move d4
more examples of how good the gleck is
E4 is a mistake and how natural is it in
this position for black to play E4 and
then F5 extremely natural but after
Knight G5 F5 you can borrow an idea from
a previous line what should white do in
order to undermine the pawn chain what
should white do in order to undermine
the pawn chain now you can't play D3
because the Pawn's already on D4 but
what's the next best thing
what's the next best thing the next best
thing is to play off three
black of course can throw in the move H6
but we don't care we have a perfectly
good Square for our Knight after he
takes up three Bishop takes F3 white is
better
why is white better here well there's a
couple of factors visually when you look
at this position
what might jump out at you is White's
bad Pawn structure but that that is a
minus in White's position but it's
there's a lot of pluses what are the
pluses well our Bishop our light squared
Bishop is better than its counterpart
because there's a pawn in F5 that's
limiting Black's influence we've got the
B file
we've got the B file so anytime black
develops their Bishop we can already
play Rook B8 Rook B1 with long-term
pressure on the pawn we have better
control of the center we've got this
Pawn chain that's really really nice and
that's restricting the activity of the
Knight and Black's King side is riddled
with light Square weaknesses that can be
exploited uh with ideas like Knight F4
Knight G6 uh maybe a well-timed check on
D5 so
definitely a much easier position to
play for white
okay hopefully that explanation makes
sense
black is unable to keep this Pawn on e4
also important like if black plays
rookie 8 here then after F takes e4f
takes C4
Queen H5 is incredibly strong and we've
got zillions of threats on all over
black screen this is already winning
okay so after after D4
uh black has to know like black has to
play a computer move essentially black
has to play a move like Bishop F5 just
ignoring ignoring the situation in the
center and this is equal rookie eight
rookie one rookie
and here the the move in my file is Pawn
take C5
with the idea of Knight takes C5 Bishop
F4 developing and I truly believe that
after Knight takes F3 Queen takes F3
white is still a little bit better from
a practical standpoint because despite
the pawn structure our pieces are much
more active our Bishop is more active
and B7 is under very serious fire
if blackplay's Bishop takes F4 here we
play Queen takes F4 and white is already
slightly better
okay
so this is the lowdown uh on this
position after Bishop G2 there is a lot
of theory here there's other moves as
well there's uh that Knight takes C3 is
by far the most common but it's not the
only move
and of course black can also Play Bishop
E7 here but your basic
idea is to play rookie one and then to
push D4 if possible if you are are
unable to push D4 the next best thing is
to play Rook B1 to throw this move in
pressuring the pawn and of course this
situation favors white because the Rook
on V8 is tied down to the defense of the
pawn of course in many situations you
can play D3
and D3 is also a completely normal move
with a very nice compact Pawn structure
and then you can get your knight around
to E4 White's position is easier to play
White's position is easier to play
that's the rundown on how to respond to
D5 now let's get to the move in the game
Bishop C5 I know this is a little bit
dry but I'm trying to give people I mean
the ultimate theme of the speedrun is
openings so that's kind of what I'm
trying to do Bishop G2
D6 D3
all right so this is all very normal H6
uh we're gonna skip the next couple of
moves because they're all very natural
castles castles and we kind of get to
uh one of the main positions of the
gleck now what's interesting is that
running this on uh stockfish it appears
that uh a a big recommendation here is
actually to play them of Knight to A4
which was not on my radar at all but we
can go after the bishop pair that is why
that is why after D3 the best move for
black is actually to start with A5
so H6 apparently is an inaccuracy
as early as move 7 we could have played
Knight A4 now why is Black's Bishop
unable to escape because if Bishop uh
before check is played then we play C3
Bishop A5 and B4 and the bishop has to
end up on B6 anyway
um if you're an Italian player this
should be a pretty familiar idea for you
so in the Italian what is the reason
that
um okay so if we go down the main line
of the Italian like castles castles D6
why is it
that in a situation like this
the the move that everybody seems to
play is Bishop B3 well it's because if
you skip this move then blacken actually
in many cases play Knight A5 such as
here and the bishop on C4 is lost so
this in general this Knight A5 move
occurs in a lot of very diverse types of
openings in the Vienna in the Vienna it
also features prominently
uh for instance let me remember the line
one second
there is a line of the Vienna or in the
king's Gambino in the king's Gambit
actually yes in the king's Gambit
there is a line
and I was looking at the king's gamut
with a student recently where you go
like Knight C3 Black Goes Knight C6 yeah
and in this position the best move is
actually Knight A4 same type of idea
you're trying to either eliminate the
bishop entirely or make it well and
again you go with the c3b4 stuff so yeah
you are trying to eliminate the bishop
so actually the best move as early as
move 7 would have been Knight A4 with a
slight Edge
but again here black should have played
A5
and here black finally did play A5 so
why is Knight A4 a good move how does
this how does this move function well
probably most people will play Bishop B6
here otherwise we take on C5 and ruin
black spawn structure now the way that
the computer plays this is actually to
play Knight takes B6 and now to play H3
King H2 and you already know the drill
so after H3 probably black will play
like this
interestingly the computer plays them of
rookie one
why rookie one what is this prophylaxis
against
this is prophylaxis what are we
preventing with the move rookie one
because otherwise it seems to make no
sense
obviously for newer players this is out
of the question because we will play B3
and the bishop is trapped so this is
nothing to worry about
yeah it's prophylaxis against the move
D5 because now if black plays D5 then
we're able to take on D5 and take on E5
and win a pawn
so rookie one prevents black from
opening up the center and allows us to
execute our plan in peace for example
Queen D7 we play King H2 black kind of
runs out of useful moves here it's hard
for black to figure out a way to improve
their position whereas for white we have
a million ways to improve our position
apart from the typical plan of preparing
F4 another plan that we could execute
here
involves playing C4 in order to
permanently prevent D5 now you might say
well what about the D4 Square well the
D4 square is very well controlled by our
Knight and because black lacks a dark
squared Bishop there is no easy way to
exploit the weakness of this Square
so let's make a couple of random moves
for black Rook f8 we play B3 and we are
actually preparing to push D4 which will
afford US an excellent clamp on Black's
position
we will go D4
and we will get sort of a dream a dream
marozzi bind setup then the bishop comes
out to B2 all our pieces are harmonious
and black is super super cramped this is
already plus minus
what if black tries for F5
well at which point
I flag tries for F5 here and let's say
plays I don't know Knight H7
right if black plays Knight H7 here
then we push D4
which is something that I pointed out
right once one of these Knights moves
away it's a very effective idea to
strike at the center we play D4 we're
threatening a fork so black kind of has
to trade and we get this excellent type
of position with the bishop pair and and
more space
uh someone else asked what about C6 and
D5 but to achieve C6 and D5 black has to
move the Knight away and the moment
black moves the Knight away the E5 Pawn
will be under Fire so black will not be
able to play D5 because the E5 final
best in addition we can play D4 with an
edge
so as a good rule of thumb there are
basically two plans in in this position
broadly speaking for white one is to
prepare D4 one is to prepare F4 if you
get the bishop pair then it is a good
idea to focus on the D4 plant otherwise
it's a good idea to focus on the F4 plan
but either way Knight A4 is an excellent
move if black does not push the a pawn
in the Gluck system Let me refresh
because I got disconnected
all right so that was a good learning
experience for me I remember this idea
but I didn't think about it during the
game so instead we decided to go for uh
the the traditional plan King H2
and 97. 97. the move that most people
play against me online is Bishop B6
and then I was planning to play Knight
D2
and the thing to remember is that even
if black plays D5 you still push F4 you
still push F4 even though things look
very very complicated in the center the
reality uh is that White's central
control is better than blacks most
people they end up releasing the tension
in the center
and now our pawns are threatening to
steamroll Black by pushing E5 and then
getting the night out to E4 things can
get really really hairy for black really
quickly and again it's hard for black to
find a useful move Queen D7 blunders to
F5
rookie eight I guess is a move that
people would default to and now we push
E5
and now we already win the game with F5
right we won a piece so black has to go
to H7 which is a great square but it it
doesn't it's not sufficient because we
bring our Knight out to E4
so let's say black trades Queens right
okay well white is already much better
because we have excellent control of the
center we can stick our Knight on B5 and
we just get a huge initiative I'm just
trying to give you a sense for why this
plan can be effective it regardless of
whether black plays D5 your next move is
going to be F4 a lot of people play
Queen D7 and that's a mistake because
after F4 why is Queen D7 a mistake who
can explain why this very natural move
helps white increase the effectiveness
of f4
this king is okay
yeah because now F5 is threatened and F5
which is already a threat now becomes
even more of a threat because it traps
the bishop it's a move that we want to
play anyway and so black essentially has
to waste a move uh moving the queen but
now we still play F5 after Bishop D7 we
can actually play Knight out to D5 very
instructive move because in the event of
the nitrate white wins on the spot with
uh the classic F6 and now our piece is
just stream into the king side with
completely decisive effect
F5 we can play Bishop takes H6
F takes C4 Bishop takes E4 just look at
the king side we're getting our Queen to
H5 this is checkmate Unstoppable
Checkmate pretty quickly
uh so this F6 idea we've we've come
across this before just shattering
shattering Black's King side you should
be familiar with this type of idea like
F6 I could probably find
I mean this is part of a general
category of ideas where you use your
pawns uh to shatter or in some way to
compromise your opponent's king position
so that you can then more effectively
bring your other pieces onto that side
of the board I remember my coach showed
me this one example
and white ended up losing this game
but this example made an impression on
me because I'd never seen this idea
before
let me see if I can um
pull up this game
this is Abraham meaning it's Millman two
strong players U.S championship by the
way
in this position
who is a Strong attacking player she
found a very very powerful idea
now most people in this position with
white would be inclined to play H5
and then G6 but she found a more
efficient way to attack on the king side
who can tell me what it is
it's not F5
it's not F5 is typical F5 if five is not
bad it's typical but she found this is
what G6 immediately yeah G6 immediately
the point is to is to lure upon to G6 so
that then when you play H5 this move
actually makes contact with a pawn and
threatens to open up the H file and if
black plays G5 you just go H6 and here
you can actually get mated like this
uh so G6 is a really really nice idea if
F takes G6 again you play H5 and again
if the point is to open up files and
diagonals for your pieces to come in and
start attacking let me see if I can find
an example of the kind of tactic that uh
that we see
here's a very simple one
this is not uh this is not a great
example but it'll you know I like I like
showing examples because it helps Hammer
home
you know various various ideas
here's the game from 1911 it's white to
play what did white do in this position
what sequence did he come up with Roy
freaking turnable black no idea who that
is
okay so this is very much yes F5
but the point is black plays Bishop
takes C4 now most people would
automatically recapture and then black
and play F6 himself and freeze the
king's side but of course the point is
white throws in F6
Intermezzo ruining the pawn structure
now it's much easier to start attacking
on the king side Bishop H6 and that's it
black is just getting squashed
and white ends up just smashing through
on the king side and then winning
actually they end up with a gleck pawn
structure which I think is kind of cute
I wasn't actually going for that here's
another example
okay here's a simpler example very very
pretty
very pretty this is a game where Boris
love ifkov who was a GM gets crushed so
again we have the structure white plays
F5 and black castles F6
not necessarily an intuitive move what
is the point of this move the point of
this move is to a shatter the king side
and B procure for white a very important
Square what is the follow-up
what is the follow-up this is an exam
these are examples of white playing the
move F6 in order to shatter the king
side Knight E5
and now Queen G3 Queen H3 white to play
and win who can find the winning
sequence now
who can find the winning sequence
now you want to go Knight G6 and I mean
most people are see this but black plays
F6 G6 so this is a classic removing the
guard removing the guard Rook takes F7
logical move removing the guard and now
Knight G6 with a fork on the queen you
win the queen back the game is over
okay so enough on this this is the basic
idea Right Moves Like F6 or almost
should be automatic for you because you
you pay such a little price you just
sacrifice the pawn but look at what you
get in return look at how bad the pawn
structure becomes so we we took a look
at a couple of various examples of this
type of technique not the same thing of
course but similar enough
if you want an example of the same thing
I could probably find that as well
I could probably find an example of the
exact Pawn structure in question
yeah here's here's here's actually a
nice one
uh very very similar
white to play
what to do
you will never guess the move
F6
how on Earth does this does this work
because black takes with a knight white
to play
white to play
Rook takes F6 yes Rook takes F6
and the tactics are as follows if
blackplay's Queen takes F6 white gets
two pieces for a rook and this monster
Square for the night white is winning
if black plays Bishop takes Bishop white
takes back with the Knight hitting the
queen and the Knight defends The Rook so
this wins easily so black plays Pawn
takes F6
we give a check on G3
we trade on B7 and we set up the mating
pattern Queen H4
and that's it the pawn on F6 is
indefensible if you play Queen E7 then
the Knight comes in and takes on F6 with
unstoppable threat of Checkmate on H7
black try D5 and white just played the
simple Rook D3
with twin threats of Rook H3 with
Checkmate and also Queen takes F6 Rook
G3 mate
okay can you do Bishop B7 first yes
probably it would be even more clinical
to play Bishop takes B7 and then Rook
takes F6 because here black can at least
take with the queen and keep going
yeah very nice exchange stack but this
is an example of the exact Pawn
structure in question uh
I actually know the guy playing Black
here John of each used to play a lot in
open tournaments I might have even
played that tournament I don't remember
all right enough
so what you're hopefully able to see is
that this idea with F4 F5 is very very
effective and of course I should point
out that
Knight D5 is not the only way for white
to continue attacking the More Kings
Indie anyway is to play G4 and then
involve the queen and play Knight F3 and
ultimately push G5 this is the more
traditional way of attacking on the king
side with pawns
um
but that is kind of the the stock idea
in the gleck system now let's get to the
move in the game Knight E7 now let's get
to the move in the game
so here we had a dilemma between kind of
two main ideas uh one was the the plan
that we executed in the game Knight D2
and F4 who can remind me what the other
one was what was the other candidate
move and I'm not talking about Bishop E3
because this is a completely separate
this is a completely separate type of
plan that we're not going to discuss in
this game because we have a lot enough
to talk about as it is
but what was the other like main
principled move here it was not Knight
H4
it was D4 it was D4 how do you know to
look for D4 well anytime the Knight
moves away from the set anytime a piece
moves backward you should ask yourself
what squares are relinquished like what
does this lesson your opponent's
influence of here clearly the answer is
D4 so this move stems naturally from
Black's previous move
but after 84 Knight D4 I didn't like the
look of the move D5
but according to the computer white is
better Knight D5 Knight T5 Ed Knight
takes D5 oh this is sexy I calculated to
this position and thought it was equal
but white winds white winds on the spot
here
white winds on the spot oh my gosh this
is lovely white to play Knight V3 I
didn't see this Knight B3
double attack on the bishop in the night
unbelievable Knight B3 ends the game so
easy to miss this retreating night move
that's it
that's it the game is over
yeah I'm trying to see if I can find
examples of that but that would be a
little bit asking for too much
you get the point Knight B3 wins the
game there's a sniper on G2 and black
cannot defend both at the same time like
either drops the Knight or the bishop so
apparently according to the computer D4
was the best move and white is slightly
better here uh just because you have
like better control of the center
uh black is likely to play a move like
Knight G6 and now if you want to you can
play F4 and expand on the king side and
restrict this Knight okay so D4 would
have been good but we decided to stick
with the main plan 92 Knight G6 F4
he takes F4 G takes F4
Knight H4 which I think is the natural
continuation for black we play Bishop H1
I missed Queen D7
but thank God we had this move F5 and I
think this is the critical position in
the whole game I actually think G5 is
essentially the losing move I think G5
is the losing move because it creates
such weaknesses on the king side that
these weaknesses are completely
irreparable I think after Knight F3 the
game just sort of spontaneously ends
Black's position combusts Black's
position just totally combusts and
Knight G6 was the follow-up move I think
here after D4 and Knight takes G5 we can
stop analyzing probably Knight takes F3
afforded more chances of survival but
still this is very very bad according to
the engine black is actually better here
but he had to find a very difficult move
the basic idea is that unless black
generates immediate chances against
White's King white is going to play
Knight F3 so we are essentially one move
away from consolidating our advantage on
the king's side and turning the tables
on the king's side black needs to do
something extravagant in order to open
up new Pathways to whites King
so Bishop E3 looks extravagant but it
doesn't really do anything we can play
Queen E1 because black is not trying to
deliver a check enough for the squares
could protect it yes D5 is the correct
move and I saw this during the game
what is the point of D5 when fd5 is not
to undermine White's Pawn chain because
white can ignore the pawn on D5 and it's
not like black really wants to play D
takes C4 what does black want
yeah Queen D6 is made in two this is
literally a mate threat it's mate in two
so black threatens Queen D6 with mate
and if white plays E5
there is this beautiful move Bishop D4
trying to shoot this Pawn away from E5
because this is still me
and the problem is that white is not in
time to consolidate if Knight F3 uh then
of course black and play Knight takes F3
and Bishop takes E5
and if white plays Queen E1
then black can play Knight takes up five
simply and if White NOW plays he takes
F6 then it's easy to observe that after
Queen D6 and Knight E3 black develops a
Monumental attack and wins all of
White's pieces
so it comes down to King's safety what
is white supposed to do after D5 but
white is supposed to play Queen to E1
immediately
uh the point is that Queen D6 is now
strongly met by E5 and the Knight on H4
is attacked but now black apparently
should play G5 very very difficult and
black is better
after Knight F3 there is the move Knight
takes F5
e takes F5 now rookie eight this is
computer chess
what happens if Queen what happens if
Queen G3
sorry let me do that again Knight F3
Knight takes F5 takes rookie eight who
can tell me what happens if the queen
tries to shelter the king from G3
here Bishop D6 pins the queen so this is
easy
so you're forcing the queen to move away
from the King now you deliver a check on
D6 and now you should identify G3 as a
potential mating square right you should
always be doing this when you're
attacking identifying potential mating
squares because that often guides your
thinking and the moment you see that you
should understand that Knight H5 is the
move because you're setting up the made
threat on G3 white has this crazy
resource 95 because if white tries to
defend it for me too black can just take
that Knight and then deliver mate so
white has 95 opening up an attack on the
Knight
Queen takes E5 Queen takes H5 and now
you have Bishop D6 again threatening
mate again threatening mate and if Queen
F3 suddenly there is also made on H2
so white is forced to give up the bishop
with Bishop F4 crazy position crazy
complications apparently black is better
at the end of it apparently the move
here is Rook fe1 and the reason why who
can find and I'll be very impressed if
somebody can find this black to play in
this position and win the game on the
spot black to play and win
F3 very good F3 check
yf3 because they're opening up a pathway
to H2 this is mate
this look at this mate oh you could
actually meet immediately Queen G3 is
mate and if Rook takes F3 then you can
simply take the Rook on E1 for starters
you could also play Queen H2 and queen
takes H1 and win so F3 wins the game why
Rook fe1 is correct because now F3 the
king can hide on F1 and white wins white
wins because the Rook on E8 is now
pinned
so that is what it all comes down to
this is high level chess right this this
is what things come down to at this
level it's these details it's crazy
tactics calculation and D5 would have
unlocked all of that uh but it was the
only move black had to find D5 and black
is better but better in quotes it's just
a wild position I wouldn't even think of
it that way I would just think of it as
a wild position anybody's game
how do you find D5 well D5 I think is a
findable move I I would expect most
title players to find D5 uh even in a
Blitz game because most title players
would sense the urgency of needing to
create counter play because they would
sense that if white is allowed to play
Knight F3 and trade off flex main
attacker then the black king is busted
in the long run because the G file is
open blacks pieces are kind of at a
standstill and White's got very easy
ways to involve a lot more pieces onto
the king side
okay so that sense of desperation kind
of leads you to the move D5 I think and
queen E1 also a findable response
because you know that the threat is
Queen D6 and queen E1 is a very
effective way of stopping the threat
while also creating a threat of white
zone but Bishop D4 in response to E5 is
an incredible move this is a very very
difficult move okay enough
let's get to the game G5 Knight F3
Knight G6 is a cute move now we started
with D4 to chase away the bishop and
Knight takes G5 I think is a very pretty
move uh but I explained it pretty deeply
during the game we're just ripping open
the king side we're not even sacrificing
that much and I think the rest the rest
of the attack essentially played itself
Bishop H6
uh Queen D3 in order to protect the H3
Pawn there was one thing I wanted to
point out which is why didn't I play F
takes G6
the reason is because after Queen takes
H3 check King G1
black has this queen G3 check and Bishop
H3 idea
after Queen E2 the Knight comes into G4
I calculate it up to this point and I
asked myself a simple question why the
heck would you even want to engage this
position when you have this beautiful
sacrifice and you have a decisive attack
why are you grabbing a knight and giving
your opponent like Limitless amounts of
counter play even if by some miracle
white is winning which is not white is
losing here because there's too many
threats there's Bishop takes D4 check
but you have to be this is what
practical chess is all about you have a
great position why grab a knight on G6
like this it's different if you're
losing and you're grabbing some material
so you have something to suffer for here
there is no point really in calculating
F6 she seeks deeply because you know
that if you don't take the Knight you've
got an amazing position where you have a
lot less risk okay so some things have
to be calculated but you shouldn't just
become obsessed with trying to figure
you're not a scientist you're you're
trying to make practical decisions at
the board and save time when possible
so are there any questions about Knight
takes G5 and how this sacrifice works
and how the subsequent attack works or
is it is it clear
because we of course spent much more
time on the first 20 moves than on the
second but every everything here was
very very straightforward Knight D5 was
straightforward and then I thought Queen
D1 is a really really cute move uh again
Queen E2 allows Bishop takes D4 so that
would be very sloppy
don't assume that just because you have
a discover check that you automatically
went that's a good lesson of this
position white is winning here with
Bishop G5 check but by a very narrow
margin
um this is a lot less convincing
so Queen D1 kills two birds with one
stone notice that at various points we
have these moves which both defend an
attack
right like Queens you want it protects
the D4 Pawn
but it also prepares to get the queen to
H5 and set up you know the mate threat
with Bishop f8 Prima Taz asks what
happens if Rook takes F7 instead of
Knight F6 The Rook takes F7 is in the
category of moves that probably does win
the game but why why sacrifice a rook
here apparently it is winning Rook F1
check
King G8 and now the move that I
mentioned during the game E5 yeah this
would be a great way to finish off the
attack but it wasn't even on my radar I
wasn't even thinking about sacking in a
rook because I saw that we had this much
simpler idea with Knight F6 that's a lot
less risky uh yeah it's in the category
of maybe even the top engine move but
it's still unnecessary which can be hard
for some people to understand but in the
presence of a simpler move like Knight
F6 Rook F7 is simply unnecessary you're
opening yourself up uh to the
possibility that the attack misfires
and that's all she wrote Queen Z1 Queen
H5 okay there were some tactics here uh
but they're all very very simple if King
G7 of course the point is that you throw
in another check on H6 uh rather than
playing Bishop F6 which is a very bad
move and here you still have to convert
queen against two minor pieces whereas
if you throw in the check first uh you
know these small details try to be
mindful of them when you're attacking
all right
yeah and Rook F5 cutting off the access
to H3 those of you who thought that this
was mate in two remember ideas like
Queen takes H3 check giving up the queen
but forcing the queen trade so that's
why we sliced off the connection then
Rook q1 getting the other piece into the
attack and now a simple deflection uh to
set up the mate on G8 and then again
setting up another queen sack with Rook
h a and that's that's how we finish the
game
okay
uh that's that's uh where we'll conclude
the speedrun game I I think it was a
good introduction to the gleck system
hopefully you can include this in Your
Arsenal and you know I think I gave you
enough to at least start playing it uh
decently there are many other lines you
have to know like Knight takes C4 is a
move here even uh Bishop before we
didn't tackle but we can't do it all in
one game I think we'll get another
chance
thanks everybody I think we're gonna end
the Stream
foreign
[Music]